est-ce que l'animal comme ils n'ont rien
fait trop on l'a vu larme à l'oeil et
halima est ému mais en même temps elle
est quand même à chaque fois elle
rappelle qu' il faut faire des jeux
raisonnable qu'il faut maîtriser les
finances que c'est des jeux pour les
parisiens elle connaît les écueils les
dangers de la grande fête olympique et
de ces lendemains qui déchantent
donc moi je trouve qu'elle est plutôt
sobre et en plus elle doit quand même
tenir compte du fait qu'au départ elle
était hostile donc c'est aussi de
trouver une cohérence dans sa démarche
mais maintenant elle va quand même
souffrir parce que il va falloir trouver
l'argent il va falloir lancer ces
chantiers avec effectivement un certain
nombre de deux
d'adversaire en embuscade qui se
saisiront du premier prétexte pour pour
essayer de renverser le cours des choses
donc je pense qu'elle pleure aussi parce
qu'elle sait ce qui l'attend ça va être
dur